plus, 60 % de participation et
est en queue de peloton, c'est
pourquoi.
- Le district de Saint-Michel
détient un record peu enviable
forte abstention aux élections
municipales. Moins d'un électeur
sur quatre est allé voter.
WISMY NOSTER, coordonateur
- Ça me dit qu'il y a du travail
à faire!
- Il a pourtant orontres entre s
et citoyens, des débats.
Mais il a une piste
d'explication.
- La pisdes citoyens et citoyen.
Vous savez, les citoyens
en arrachent quand même
quotidiennement,
pour se vêtir. La disponibilité,
c'est un luxe qu'ient
pas se payer.
- Ici, le revenu médian
que la moyenne montréalaise.
La mairesse élue promet d'aller
vers ces citoyens désintéressés.
LAURENCE LAVIGNE LALONDEhel
- Faire des consultationssur le,
là où sont les gens pour
les inviter à par comprendre lee
la municipalité dans leur vie,
et je pense que ça, ça va avoir
un impact bien évidemment
- Au terme de ce scrutin qui a
coûté 20 millions $, seulement
38 % de participation.
en tire une conclusion.
ANDRÉ
Élections Montréal
- Ce que ça veut d c'est qu'uneé
a décidé pour la majorité,
ce qui est pas tout à fait
le sens de la démocratie.ortes,,
les candidats ont constaté
que les communications n'étaient
pas claires.
difficultés à comprendre qui
était inscrit sur scrit sur scr.
Je pense que moi, je fais partie
de ces gens qui onla lettrla le:
Comment ça se fait que je su
pas inscrite sur la liste
électorale?eu
beau déployer des efforts.
- Vulgariser les informations,
mais malgré tout, nous sentons
à ce niveau-là.
les conclusions
qui doivent être tirées,
mais il qu'il y a eu beaucoup
plus d'efforts cet
qu'en 2017. Quand je vous dis
quatre jours, c'est 42 h de8.
- Et la majorité des électeurs
ont voté par anticipation.
Le dispositif pourrait
être répété dans quatre ans